now we can
whimper we can whine or we can fight
we'll fight we'll fight to fight fight
fighting fight
fighting
[Music]
we're gonna fight we're gonna fight
and then there's the fight
[Music]
we're gonna fight we're gonna fight
we're gonna fight we're gonna fight we
are gonna fight we're gonna
fight we're gonna fight we're gonna
fight we're gonna fight number one
[Music]
this election was over and then they did
dumps they call them dumps
big massive dumps
[Music]
they say it's statistically impossible
[Music]
all i want to do is this i just want to
find
11 780
votes which is one more that we have
because we want to say you know what
they did and you're not reporting it
that's
it
you know that's a number of 11 779
that's the number of 11
779 that's the number of 11
700 111 179 1199
that's something i think everyone at
least that's the number that everyone
agrees on
but that's the difference uh in the
votes
but we've had uh hundreds of thousands
of
ballots that we're uh we're we're able
to
actually we'll get you a pretty accurate
number you don't need much of a number
because the number that
in theory i lost by the number of
hundred 11 seventy nine
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
for the land of the grace
[Music]
okay let's uh i won't keep subjecting
people to that that that's a bit much i
understand
um welcome everybody i was planning and
hoping to cover the senate vote on
the 1.9 trillion dollar covid stimulus
package a very large package but one
that's been reshaped to some degree by
the senate
um but they are now in the process of
reading the entire thing
which could take somewhere up to 10
hours let's listen in a little bit to
what's going on in the senate
requirements under section 246.8 of
title vii
code of federal regulations as an effect
on the date of the enactment of this act
section 1107 meals and supplements
reimbursements for individuals
a program for at-risk school children so
as you can see
um this is just the latest delay tactic
from republicans to slow this down and
inevitably
you know it's going to pass it'll be a
watered-down version
that passes and um it
this is what they're doing so i did an
entire segment which just went live on
youtube
nine minutes ago about how this is being
changed one of the changes that
republicans had no part in negotiating
it was negotiated between joe biden and
senate democrats
is that the eligibility will be stricter
instead of phasing out to
zero at a hundred thousand dollars a
year in income
the checks will phase out to zero at
eighty thousand dollars a year in income
that money will instead go to hospitals
is the proposal from gene shaheen so
still
1.9 trillion but
reallocating it and for me it's less
about
oh does someone earning 96 000 deserve
money
it's less about that like you could
argue yes you could argue no
even with the new restrictions it'll
still help 86 percent of households
it's more about like what the hell are
we doing here
either way this isn't going to be
supported by republicans
so what what who why are these
negotiations happening and they're
happening because
of people like joe manchin and gene
shaheen for whom
the house version of this bill was just
too loose
too liberal um you know
it's when when i said in november
that even with the two senate seats from
georgia you still have to deal with joe
manchin
that wasn't like a hypothetical that was
not an imaginary thing
you really have to deal with joe manchin
and others and
they don't want it they're they're to
the right of where the average of the
democratic party is
so that is the negotiation that was done
and
uh that's that that's what it is let's
listen a little bit more here this is
riveting stuff
7 usc 2011 note public law
116-127 is amended
one in subsection a a by striking
during fiscal years 2020 and 2021
and inserting in any school year in
which there is a public health emergency
designation
and b by inserting or in a covered
summer period following a school session
after
in session yeah so this this could go on
for 10 hours
um this is a complete waste of taxpayer
money it's a waste of senate time
it's just grandstanding by uh by by
republicans and it's completely pathetic
and humiliating for everybody involved
including me including me pepe xanadu
says via super chat would i consider a
vegan flan
would i consider it what would i
consider eating it or would i consider
it flan it can't really be flan the
whole point of flan is milk and eggs
so i don't i think that it's counter
it's it's um
it's it's an impossibility you can't
possibly have a vegan flan
alex says who's the senator speaking
these these are not members of the
senate
these are this is senate staff that's
reading the bill
emergencies during summer the secretary
of agriculture
may permit a state agency to extend a
state agency plan
approved under subsection b for not more
than 90 days
for the purpose of operating the plan
this is crazy i'm gonna try to check
out like how some news outlets are
covering this let me see if i can find
like
uh nbc live
let's see what nbc live is saying about
this
just to get a sense of what the coverage
is looking like
here we go
he called you not
ben i honestly can't imagine what it is
like uh to look at uh
these kinds of forms and read all this
stuff all day long we are so thankful
that you do it and report we're not even
covering it we appreciate you
thank you maybe they go to it now
the senate working with heightened
security at the capitol today
hopefully voting on covett relief but
there might be a new delay from the
republicans
no matter how long it takes the senate
is going to stay in session to finish
the bill this week
right the american people deserve
nothing less
nbc news capitol hill correspondent
garrett hake joining me now
garrett uh first what is security like
there today and what are you hearing
from lawmakers who are actually working
on the hill today are they worried about
these threats
and quite frankly are you allison inside
the building it's not too different from
any other day that we've had since about
january
7th so anyway they're going to continue
reading the bill and
and we'll keep an eye on it there's a
bunch of other things that i want to go
over with you guys
um mikhail browning has an interesting
idea which is if one requests the bill
to be read the senate rule should make
the requester be the one to actually
read it yeah i don't think there's any
way to enforce that it's a nice idea
i just don't uh i don't see any any way
that you could possibly enforce that
chakaseki says david is there a
republican amendment to add the cat in
the hat and the sneetches into the
relief bill
to circumvent cancel culture i would
like that doc
that would be a really great thing i
would um i
i would love to be able to do that all
right let me get into some things
uh because we do we do have some time
here i uh
i've mentioned to you guys before that i
am um a participant in a documentary by
our good friend james fletcher called
the accidental president
i now have four clips of my
participation let's just look at them
this is available on amazon and apple tv
i interviewed james on the podcast today
and check this out i've been promising
these for a while let me get set up to
play these for you
uh okay let me make this a little bit
smaller
these are some of the clips in which i
appear
in the film the accidental president let
me get this sized right
all right here we go listen to this
it was the idea that trump was assigning
people names
that conveys a sort of authority right
don't worry about it little marco i will
all right well it's here big
big dog don't worry about it don't worry
about it a little marco
sometimes the only way to deal with the
bully is to knock him on his ass
he's always calling me little marco
another man the guy he's taller than me
he's like six
two which is why i don't understand why
his hands are the size of someone who's
five
two okay so there's one clip um here's
another one
james just said i said can you send a
couple clips that i'm in here's another
one entire
country oh god hold on it's going to
resize every single time that's really
annoying
uh here's piers morgan
all right here's the next clip hold on
oh dear god this is going haywire
laughing at him they were mocking him
donald trump has been saying that he
will run for president as a republican
which is surprising since i just assumed
he was running as a joke
[Applause]
there was just no serious thought given
to him as a as a candidate it's obvious
that the republicans think trump's gonna
lose
all right so there's that clip um
here's one more any minute now
all the news coverage just got sucked up
and focused on him because he
continued to be the most interesting
story you can't even remember what the
other candidates were about
but the media is not the one that told
all of his competitors
not to do interviews they did they were
running an old game and an old playbook
trump to his credit understood that new
media world and he took advantage of it
there's no question about it
that led to just an unconscionable
amount of free
media coverage that we could sort of
quantify in in dollars it would be a
really really high number
you know people say that he got a
billion dollars in free media in the
process so there's that
was negative a lot of that was would
have been okay and then lastly one last
clip these are clips from the accidental
president a documentary film in which i
appear
you had a few different contingents that
were starting to maybe look for a way to
coalesce around
something to replace president obama
knowing knowing that he'd be leaving
i think liberals and conservatives were
both looking for someone there i am
right alongside matt
schlapp from uh from cpac the american
conservative union
all right so that's the film called the
accidental president it's it's available
a bunch of different places i watched it
on amazon
and if people are interested you can
find it there
um so that is that few other super chats
oh just one brumall says can dem pass
marijuana legalization with 51 votes or
do they need to end the filibuster
irrelevant because they are not going to
even think about legalization
joe biden's looking for
decriminalization and that's going to be
the path through
that being said i don't know if i um i
don't know the answer to whether
any of it can be done with a simple
majority
all right so there is that um
by the way i have my i i have not opened
it yet
i have down here my gold
youtube million subscriber plaque it
came in yesterday and a letter from
susan wojcicki the ceo of youtube i was
thinking maybe i would open it on
on the stream today um this is the
hundred thousand subscriber one look at
how little it is
the the gold million subscriber one is
massive it's a massive package and i
would definitely be willing to open it
but maybe i'll wait i mean i think we
need to
we need to do something when it comes to
making some progress on these member
numbers let's see what we've got
um we've got okay
i guess we have one one person signed up
via twitch
that puts us at one and i think we've
got nothing happening
on the website right now yeah i'll wait
i mean maybe let's at least get to like
30 or 40
members otherwise i'll just wait and
maybe we'll do it next week or you know
in a few years or something like that
um all right other things that i have
going on here
as many of you know today is march 4th
today is the day that many q anon people
said i don't know if they believed it
but they said that donald trump would be
re-inaugurated as president
it didn't it didn't happen i guess
there's a few hours left in the day
still
but now they are again shifting the goal
posts this is an article
from newsweek q anon theorists by the
way
using the term theorist it's it's like
the most generous
is it q anon academics have switched the
date the
this is you know if you look at the
quote research these people are doing i
think the term theorist is maybe a bit
much
q anon theorists switch date to march
20 after no trump inauguration
call the fourth false flag as federal
law enforcement agencies braced for q
anon conspiracy theorists
to engage in potential acts of violence
on thursday
leading affiliates of the far-right
extremist movement
seem to amend formerly held beliefs
about the significance of march 4th and
then it goes on to say
um originally they believed trump would
resume today
because the inauguration day before 1933
was march 4th
then it was switched to january 20th
okay so you kind of know the idea
um and then it goes on to say um
the uh march they are now describing
march 4th
as a false flag constructed by
mainstream news organizations and
internal double agents to deceive the
true q anon proponents so remember
the january 6th riots were fake trump
supporters
and now the people who were saying march
4th were
fake q anon supporters let me see where
the march
20th thing is where is march 20th
i want to see the explanation for that
there's just so much nonsense here
uh ah here it is some q and on
supporters seem to rebrand the march 4
conspiracy
in the wake of community suspicion two
individuals affiliated with the false
theories simply suggested that it would
take
place sometime in spring one man
identified as ken told the washington
post reporter dave weigel we love dave
dave's a friend of the show
that the former president will be
inaugurated again on march 20th
in comments over the military ken also
believes that trump is still in command
of the military
and biden is acting as president as a
ruse while the pope and others are
rounded up
why are they arresting the pope by the
way what is the role
what is the role of the pope in this
entire thing um do they hate the pope
because he's argentinian
i don't know i don't know but it's uh
it's really really bad
all right we have sworn off all troy
york voicemails for some time
because the i sort of made the decision
that the ones that were coming in were
shallow and pedantic
but i am going to put it to you guys
again
i have two new troy york voicemails i'm
i'm not gonna lie to you and say these
are the best things i've ever seen
but i do want to give people an
opportunity to be heard
as to whether now having had a couple
weeks off from troy york you want to
hear from him
okay so i'm pasting the link to a straw
poll
in twitch and i'm also going to paste a
link to the exact same straw poll
in youtube and it's going to be up to
you guys
okay you guys can decide whether i play
the new troy york voicemails
if people are sick of troy york then
this is the this is the place to vote
just tell me you're sick of it
and um and then nothing will happen now
i'd again
are we is straw poll having some kind of
an issue
because i'm not seeing any votes tallied
let me refresh this this is weird we had
this issue last time with straw poll
why aren't why why isn't it coming up
that's bizarre
it's not registering people's votes okay
let me do oh whoa here we go whoa whoa
whoa is that possible 163 yeses that
doesn't make sense either
no i'm not buying this let me do a
different one
okay we're gonna do a different one
should i play
new troy oh wait a second i guess it is
working hold on it is correct okay all
right all right all right
wow the nose winning for the first time
ever
the audience may be completely kyboshing
playing of troy york
voicemails every time we've put it to a
vote before people have voted yes
wow with almost 500 votes the no's have
it
it looks like the audience is saying no
to troy york if that's the case i will
abide by that
i will abide by it 464 let's see when
the next
dump of votes comes in
464 just a slight slight edge for the
nose
seems to be updating on some kind of
really strange schedule i don't know
in the meantime thank you to um
thanks to durgies as well
as warrant and a couple of other people
three people who signed up via twitch
putting us
at four um there it is another dump of
votes
5 16 52 to 48 people are saying
no troy york voicemails i'll paste the
link a couple more times in twitch
just for people who want to get those
last votes and by the way people voting
by typing yes or no
that doesn't count okay that doesn't
count you have to vote in the straw poll
only straw poll voting counts
i see people typing yes and no
all right we'll give it we'll give it
another moment or two and see if there's
any updates
but right now the no's having it
i don't believe this is any kind of
voter suppression everybody's allowed to
vote
um 516 votes it just seems like it's
updating on a very strange delay
after this we'll vote on whether this
vote is is legit you know
mikael says david pakman straw poll
voters are as divided as the country
that's that's absolutely right uh oh my
god it switched to yes
with the latest dump of votes we now are
at 52 to 48 on the yes
let's maybe leave it for one more update
last opportunity for people to vote and
then
uh maybe we will hear about our uh
we will hear the troy york voicemail 721
votes
this was a this was a no mirage earlier
where the early vote was
skewed towards no uh wow now plus 31 for
the yeses it's starting to potentially
get out of reach
and we we may have to call it soon
people continuing to ask for the link
okay i think i've pasted it about 20
times now
i'll do it one more time in twitch one
more time in youtube
um 774 votes the margin is only 24 votes
from the standpoint of yes this is
this is this it's michigan all over
again
now down to 51.49 the margin is only 24
votes now with 800 so far
um i am going to set a timer i mean i
have to end it at some point
i'm going to set a timer for one more
minute and it is starting
we are going to have just one more
minute to vote 55 seconds
and then we will end it
oh wow yes just taking over i think it's
now mathematically out of
reach 2251 plus 51 on the yes now
40 seconds to go should i play new troy
york voicemails i am not pasting the
link anymore i've already pasted it too
many times
um over a thousand votes this is some of
the highest turnout that we have ever
had
ever had uh about 20 16 17
of our entire audience right now has
voted which is huge
25 seconds to go and we will end it
i have two troy york voicemails it is up
to you guys people typing yes
in the chat your vote doesn't count
you can't call a friend when you want to
vote for president you have to vote
and you actually have to vote in the
poll okay seven
seconds to go and uh i think it is over
three two one zero the yeses have won
ladies and gentlemen
oh there it is it is over
all right so the yeses did win the now
i'm not
committing to playing the entire
voicemails because they are trash
but uh okay let's listen to the first
one new troy york material
yes david pakman you are a conspiracy
theorist there is no q anon and
basically what you people on the left
are trying to do is
to silence the opposition voice to the
democratic party you have auntie for
pretending
pretending to be this q anon fan wow
he's like hitting every every nutty
claim i see and uh
the january 6 attack was done by the
left wing
not trump supporters they infiltrated
the
protests and now you lunatics on the
left
are gonna keep talking staging some
events for tomorrow
and basically it will be a lie and if
anything does
but nothing happened so i guess if if
antifa is really the or
or if antifa is really behind q anon
they didn't do anything
here's one more he left this one at 4 49
a.m this morning
very very normal time to be calling a
talk show
and the real conspiracy is people like
you
pushing q anon and i
the amount of political divisive
and fearful hate you spread on youtube
you
you should really be taken off youtube
because you what you do
[Music]
through broadcast is a disgrace
and outrage yeah all right i'm done it
is really i guess it is pretty pedantic
you guys are
the i think maybe the vote went the
wrong way i think it really probably
should it should have been a no on troy
york so anyway
we're gonna put another temporary
suspension on troy york
uh no doubt about it all right thanks
very much uh so that's that thanks to
jimmy stanley
for signing up via twitch and also thank
you to
who one other person who signed up 17
uh 17 which puts us at six very much
appreciate that and
website memberships are in play you can
sign up at joinpakman.com
couponcodebetter21
for a huge discount all right let's get
to some super chats oh
let's just check in on the senate
reading of the coveted bill let's see
401 a state educational agency shall not
in fiscal year 2022 or 2023 reduced
state funding is calculated on a
per-pupil basis
for any highest power you should really
get a speed reader
david huge fan of the show do you have a
bidet would you consider getting one
what are you talking about dude uh
lauren
if i wanted to listen to a troy i'd talk
to my dad
not entirely sure what we're voting on
which makes me representative of the
average u.s voter
yes voting without knowing what's going
on the nos were winning until massive
dumps of illegal votes came in
after the polls closed stop the steal
rumor has it these votes are sent to
uh are being sent to a remote location
in cambodia
um okay there we go so
that is that um
all right very good very very good
uh okay
all right so we've got that excellent
let's look at a couple of different
clips
uh oh oh oh one thing i i'm
i'm willing to do this just to see what
people think
yesterday when i spoke to stephen
kenneth destiny bonnell ii
i pointed out that i have no clue what's
going on on the kind of online left and
online right and a few people wrote to
me and said
david you might find the stuff going on
interesting so just like
check out something and what was
recommended by a bunch of people
was this recent debate between
uh bastiat and va'ash okay
so i'm just gonna listen to a few
minutes of it
i don't know what these things are like
i've said before i
i don't have time to do two three four
hour debates with people
but let's just sort of like see what's
going on and i'm gonna i don't know
let's just see what it's about this is a
debate
two-hour debate welcome bosh it seems
bastiat is still muted
uh capitalism was already lost it's over
what a cringe lord
how you doing man i am i am doing okay
i already have no idea what this is and
i'm already sort of like this is
probably not for me all things
considered uh
all right let's skip ahead already
and tonight's prize eternal
introductions
this match uh due to recent events it
was a little harder to get going than
would have thought
and of course it has costs if everybody
has still going introduction
hearing his explanation for how it will
work better than what we've got now
is fundamentally my goal is individual
freedom and the results
that come through a capitalist economy
the improving standard of living that i
think has made the world a better place
particularly over the last say 40 years
so
that's where i stand wonderful next i
will be thrown
over to avash for a similarly timed
intro yeah so nobody is satisfied with
the world as it exists
everybody wants to make some
improvements and everybody wants to make
those improvements in certain ways
some improvements if made in ineffectual
ways
will beget negative results and some
negative direction
where's that feedback coming from you
guys hear that there's like a duplicate
audio
hold on i hear an echo oh he hears it
too i'll mute my mind
okay gotcha and some directions one can
pursue even if
well-intentioned lead to negative
outcomes
in my personal opinion i believe that
that which i advocate for principally
uh that is to say selective
decommodification and for
uh uh market socialism worker
cooperatives
are inc what like why don't i care about
this can someone explain to me and we've
had vash on the show
and uh he's a perfectly you know nice
guy we had a great conversation
we had a 25-minute conversation that was
sort of narrowly focused like
why do i why why is this just why does
this do nothing for me
because no one's saying anything
lack of professionalism because it's not
real it's all rambling
because i'm a pragmatist i don't care
about it because it's not practical
i i i don't know guys i struggle with
this stuff like i get invited to stuff
all the time and they're like it'll be a
three-hour conversation it's just like
no i'd rather just read
let's listen to a little more let's just
skip ahead and see what's going on
one hour left so uh what have you we've
gotten to the we have only one hour left
point oh my god okay let's continue
many times on stream and in videos and
everywhere
is that i think that these systems
should be improved not to perfection
should there ever be such a thing
but as much as we're capable of
improving it and i think that since you
seem to agree
that you don't like power imbalances and
trade relations that you and i would
have a similar goal in promoting
economic autonomy for the developing
world
it depends i suppose what you mean by
autonomy for the developing world if you
mean like autarky
if that's what you mean by independence
then no i think that seems to be where
it's been tried
usually because you use a word like
independence
independence like they're not entirely
dependent on sweatshops that are owned
by foreign companies to survive
independents like like the united states
where we have a lot of power to engage
in trade relationships on our own terms
because we're i think you know one of
the things about this that i think is
problematic is like
for me it's not an attention span thing
like i can sit
and read complex theory for an hour
and sort of go through it and and
synthesize it and go back when i need to
and that
that type of thing i i feel like i
get so much more out of that than
something like this
where it's two hours and and it's sort
of like it in a sense it's an
arbitrarily set time period but at the
same time there's like kind of
odd amounts of time and by odd i mean
sort of like arbitrary amounts of time
devoted to each piece and it's never
really clear like has a point now been
made
have we uh it it seems like it's just
kind of like
content for the sake of content like
let's do a two-hour video
and i don't i don't know i don't know
um
yeah people say is is this how is this
less vapid than what you do
i'm not saying it is or isn't what what
i'm saying is uh
i think that i deliberately
i believe that people mostly are going
to learn
by sort of like um self-directed
consumption of history
and philosophy and economic theory
and and sort of that sort of thing i
don't think people are going to learn
much from watching me in a three-hour
debate which is why i just don't
do them um oh people are saying a lot of
people build their opinions what by
watching stuff like this interesting
yeah no i mean listen i'm sure all these
people are really nice
i i know vosh that's the only person i
know and we had a great conversation on
our show
i don't know i just don't know the
i just don't it's just it's just not for
me i guess is what i'm saying
it's not for me um okay
if other people learn that's fantastic i
think that's great who am i
i mean i'm not saying it's bad i'm just
saying for me it's not the type of thing
i like to watch and it's not
something i look to participate in
uh okay i want to say thanks to john
benson
john just signed up at joinpackman.com
and his new member number seven today
i also want to say thanks to the four
people who just grabbed twitch prime
subs
putting us at 11 for the day appreciate
it guys let's check in briefly on the
senate reading of the coveted relief
bill
1-0 institute for educational sciences
in addition to amounts otherwise
available there is appropriated to the
department of education for fiscal year
2021 out of any money in the treasury
not otherwise appropriated
100 million dollars to remain so they're
they're still going let's look at some
of the comments from folks
wade flores says david for most of these
long-form debate conversations the best
thing you can do is play it in the
background and play a video game this is
typically how i listen to destiny
that's interesting my equip i'll usually
find
like philosophy lectures when i'm doing
that that's more appealing to me
um oliver says your show has a natural
flow a guided path to a logical end vosh
debate seems a haphazard circular
argument with no clear lesson
dereten says discussions about political
theory by people with no skin in the
game
ultimately is pointless they aren't
producing a change or creating material
us congress has the most brain-dead
group of idiots running the asylum if
they had any clue they would finally
learn their abcs
talk your ish dave keep doing what
you're doing my friend
i blast off daily with a bidet highly
recommend
david do you support the recognition of
native american mixed bloods
in the u.s don't know enough about that
eugene i'm curious about the bidet
circle back to that
i'm from argentina a country where
bidets are standard
totally standard bidets in argentina
complete uh complete normal just
standard
big thank you to evelyn harris evelyn
thank you you're a great american to
quote sean hannity even though i don't
even know if you're american
but evelyn i really appreciate you
signing up on my website
joinpakman.com all right let's get to a
few
other things here uh okay wait so let me
i
did that we did a little bit of the
debate
thing oh okay the cancel culture stuff
it's it's nuts what's going on um this
is
jim jordan i by the way i find it really
strange that jim jordan will often stand
in his own office when he's being
interviewed like you could sit down dude
anyway this is the latest explosive
claim
about so-called cancel culture i think
you're right i think americans are just
fed up with this all i mean
you know first it was kermit the frog in
the muppets mr potato head then now
you know dr seuss but don't forget they
also came after you guys they come after
fox news one american news and newsmax
too so
this is frightening where the left wants
to go i have said i think this is the
biggest threat to freedom we face
because
dr seuss enterprises saying we won't
continue publishing six books at our
discretion
is the biggest threat to freedom the i
would argue that the world faces not
even just americans
you know if you do you have a
functioning first amendment
and of course the first amendment has
nothing
nothing to do with the decision by dr
seuss just couldn't
couldn't have less to do with it besides
allowed to talk
do you have free speech when only the
left can determine what gets said
and of course that's also a complete
they will not stop with this cancel
culture stuff
it's on and on and on and on
people asking about excuse me the coupon
code the coupon code's right there it's
better21
um all right so there's jim jordan and
then this
is also funny joe biden used the term
neanderthal
yesterday and he said that you know
governors like the governor of texas who
were just cancelling all coveted relief
i'm sorry not canceling coveted relief
canceling covet guidelines
that it's neanderthal thinking and
someone wrote to me and said david
they're saying that it's not appropriate
to use the term neanderthal and i said
that can't possibly be
there's no way listen to what senator
marshall blackburn
said listen to this is crazy
this is speciesist is
tennessee guilty of neanderthal thinking
senator
well stuart we were called neanderthals
when i led the fight against imposition
of a state income tax
in tennessee so you know what i did i
started the neanderthal caucus
because neanderthals are hunter
gatherers
they're protectors of their family by
the way what's that beeping in the
background is that a phone what is that
they are resilient they're resourceful
they tend to their
own so i think joe biden needs to
rethink what he is saying
about the states that are choosing to
move away from these
masked mandates in tennessee we have a
lot of people that are moving away
from mass mandates and our counties
yeah a lot of people who are just
refusing to wear masks
you know what our budget is in good
shape
our kids are back in school people are
going back to work
those that have been adversely impacted
by covet that still need targeted timely
relief
you've got communities coming around
these individuals
so a principled and defiant defense
defensive neanderthals and i actually
believe we need to go to bat for homo
erectus
i think that if if we allow the history
of homo erectus
to be uh erased um i
i believe we will never never ever ever
forgive ourselves never ever
oh and okay yeah and people are
mentioning the um yeah
let me pull that up that's that's good
there's these clips actually aaron is
the one who posted them
um abbott and and patrick in texas
of course they just opened the state
wide open
and they're already blaming immigrants
for covid it's it's wacky
let me find these clips uh here's dan
patrick
this is the lieutenant governor of texas
listen to him and as governor abbott
mentioned i would call neanderthal
thinking of allowing people to cross the
border illegally with kovid
tested positive and put them on a bus
and as governor abbott mentioned i would
call neanderthal
thinking okay so there's that and then
here is um
here's the governor of texas last night
the biden administration was releasing
illegal immigrant illegal immigrants
into our communities who had coveted
the bot administration was spreading
covet in
south texas yesterday because of their
lack of constraint
of testing and quarantining lack of
constraint of testing let me see if i
hold on a second
try to understand that lack of
constraint
of testing
that's weird i don't even know what that
means people who'd come across the
border illegally
the bright administration uh was
exposing texans to covet
that is neanderthal type approach uh to
dealing with the kova situation
what about australopithecus um
it's it's crazy and you know they they
bragged all throughout trump's
presidency
border crossings are like at nil because
of the wall which they didn't even build
and all of this stuff
and now all of a sudden biden's been
president five weeks and coveted in
texas is because of undocumented
immigrants and then of course the
the other funny thing about it is the
active case rate in mexico is
significantly lower than in the united
states i even have the data here let me
see
um if you look at united states
so usa cases per capita 88
000 and then mexico cases per capita
16 000. it's one-sixth it
the people coming from mexico if they
are coming
which supposedly they weren't because of
the great job trump did with the wall he
didn't build
if they are coming they are only
one-sixth as likely to have kovid as a
general statistic you could say well no
the people coming over
are more likely to have it than the ones
staying in mexico city or whatever
it it's it's wild absolutely wild wild
wild
so um that's greg abbott and lieutenant
governor dan patrick
uh blaming mexicans for covid
in texas thanks to gordon hall for
signing up on my website
joinpacman.com gordon i really
appreciate that
uh thank you so much for signing up
gordon taking advantage of the coupon
code
better21 what a perfect sign up
absolutely perfect
and also thanks to the three people who
just grabbed memberships on twitch
that's
gem austin smith and
sue me long gifted a subscription
um as a reminder oh yeah because a lot
of people don't know
if you have an amazon prime account you
can sign up via twitch prime for
free they're called bezos bucks you're
taking five bucks from bezos
and sending it to us it's a beautiful
beautiful thing
all right other super chats have i heard
trump's georgia call turn into a song
by shomo yoho i haven't
i'll check it out though buffalo five
knives says i think structured debate
can be boring because the structure
rarely lends itself to meaningful back
and forth better to hear experts
salon through issues even with no
ultimate conclusions
interesting as someone who's genetically
four percent neanderthal i'm deeply
offended by biden's diss of my heritage
that's an outrage
yeah you know what let me see if i can
pull up my 23 and me
i am i am highly neanderthal
that will come as a shock i think to
many in the audience
let me see if i can find it don't even
remember my login info let me see here
uh
hmm i don't even know my password to
this nonsense
was it is 23andme the one that measures
your neanderthal dna
i think i'm getting in yeah i'm 100
ashkenazi jewish but from the standpoint
of neanderthal i tested quite high
let's see i would like to pull this up
i think i got my password right but it's
just kind of hanging
we'll come back to it i'll just let it
try to log in
canceling senator holly's book now dr
seuss what a blow for the genre of vapid
fiction and imaginary problems
yeah very much so i'll get to some other
super chats momentarily oh
nobody's able to log into 23 and me okay
something must be going on
let's listen to a little more or we are
getting closer to a vote on covid
for sector during and after the cove 19
public health
emergency b qualified child care
provider
to be qualified to receive a sub grant
under this paragraph a provider shall be
an eligible child care provider that on
the date of the submission of an
application for the sub grant was either
one open interview child care services
or two
close due to public health financial
hardships or other reasons relating to
the covenant 19
public health emergency c sub grant
amount
the amount of such a sub grant to a
qualified child care provider shall be
based on the providers yeah i think all
the senators are gone some people are
saying check my ancestry dna oh oh i'm
in i'm in hold on
let's see oh the website is so toxically
slow right now
i can't even believe how slow this is
dna relatives traits ancestry
composition
ancestry and traits overview yeah let's
see
oh no not again the same guy is gonna
have to be banned again it looks like
on twitch yep that's too bad all right
all right i'll let it keep loading uh 23
and me is just
so slow that i'm not even able to handle
it okay
well it is what it is we'll see if we
can get back to it
all right very good okay so we took care
of
all of that um oh thanks to rx queen
matt sb lola supernova doughboy
just justin andrew watson the gemini
shut up megs gem h austin smith today a
whole bunch of people 11 people in fact
grabbing uh twitch subs which i very
much appreciate
and uh all right yeah
let's just do the um let's do the
let's do the the youtube plaque unveil
all right so as many of you know we
recently hit a million youtube
subscribers now in fact we're already at
1.3 million youtube subscribers that's
okay
but i have here this is our old
100 000 youtube subscriber
silver button okay i have here
a huge package look at this thing from
youtube
this is the i've not opened this yet
this
is the gold button we're going to do
this right now and i have an idea for
some memes
let's first take a look at it i have a
beautiful letter from
youtube ceo susan wojcicki i don't know
why
i don't even believe it's pronounced
that way but that's the way people tell
me it's pronounced
okay david if you took one step for each
subscriber you have
do you know how far that would get you
for starters over 13 times
around the perimeter of beijing or
14 times around paris
oh people are saying go full screen okay
i'll i will i will
uh or 15 times around new york that's
because you now have
over 1 million subscribers
but your influence stretches beyond that
of a single city
through your incredible cree i'm sure
this is like a custom letter just for me
through your incredible creativity and
dedication you have built a dynamic
community that stretches across
continents and binds people together
from all corners of the globe
they come together to be inspired by
your unique
voice and vision youtube
started with the idea of a platform
where anyone can broadcast
oneself and you've done exactly that no
dreams are too big
and no details too small when it comes
to the care that you put into engaging
your community that's right that's why
we just banned 20 people on youtube
to honor your remarkable achievement we
are proud
to present you with the gold creator
award we hope that it will inspire you
and remind you how much you mean to so
many
we know that this milestone only begins
to tell your story that's right we also
have voicemails you were also part
of a groundbreaking group of creators
who are building the next generation
of new media companies every day you are
reinventing how stories are created and
shared
and we can't wait for the next chapter
of your story
yours sincerely susan wiziski
ceo youtube alright
so there is the letter from susan let's
now get to
the actual thing here we go
all right there it is
wow look at that and i'm gonna remove
this stuff
hold on a second what's going on here oh
wait a second
oh hold on this isn't even part of it
let's open this up
there it is folks look at that that is
massive massive massive package
look at that thing isn't that something
now what i'm going to do is i think that
something that would be great for this
from the standpoint of memes
would be you know how trump used to sign
an executive order and kind of move this
back and forth
i'm gonna do that and maybe people can
then superimpose funny stuff onto this
i'll just move the mic and do it then it
can be
gift and gift and turned into stuff all
right here we go
i hope that's enough and then now it can
be turned into stuff
um this is nice i have to tell you i
mean
this is the hundred thousand one
this is the million it's just it's not
even close
not even close all right
so that's that it is metal yeah people
ask this is
all oh wait is that metal no it's not
solid metal
i guess it's metal plated or something
like that
all right very good so we've gotten that
uh out of the way okay
patricker says you're now legally
obligated to put it in your background
like the other youtubers
yeah i don't really have a place to do
it
i mean i guess it could conceivably go
would this be on screen like right here
i could have the edge of it just right
here maybe
or even down like on this block oh
that's not a bad idea actually
i wonder if i could put it
that's not a bad idea actually that's
not bad that's not bad
okay good so we did we did it
we did it english wachitsuki
polish vasitskiy voysitsky all right
uh congratu congrats on the shiny from
youtube
okay very good very good we did it
um soon i'll be doing makeup tutorials
yeah all right let's listen to what's
happening in the senate
administrative costs for which funds are
appropriate under subsection treasury
not otherwise appropriated
two million five hundred thousand for
the fiscal year 2021 to remain available
until expended
the federal administrative costs of
carrying out subsections
c and d section two twenty two
zero five child abuse abuse prevention
and treatment
in addition to amounts otherwise
available there is appropriated to the
secretary of health and human services
for fiscal year 2021
out of any money in the treasury not
otherwise appropriate the following
amounts to remain available through
september 30 of 2023. 250 million
for um carrying out the program
authorized under section 201 of the
child abuse prevention and treatment act
42 usc
5116 while shall be allocated without
regard to section
204 of such act 42 usc 5116 d4
and she'll be allotted to yeah so
they're they're uh they're still going
there i
i do have my neanderthal dna stuff
pulled up let's see if we can take a
look at it now
um here we go
let's see here uh
[Music]
okay david you have more neanderthal dna
than 42
of other customers oh that's not that
much that means i have less neanderthal
dna than 58
so that's actually that's actually not
that much
altogether your neanderthal ancestry
accounts for less than two percent of
your dna
under two percent neanderthal dna this
report highlights associations between
your neanderthal variants and your
traits but it doesn't explore how other
factors may be involved okay
i have one variant associated with
having a worse sense of direction
that's interesting you have one variant
associated with being a better sprinter
than distance runner
i think that that's probably true i
think that that's probably true
you have one variant associated with
having more dandruff oh i don't that's
not true
i mean well i mean more more this is all
relative
uh that's interesting
you have zero variance associated with
having difficulty
discarding rarely used possessions
that's true i love getting rid of stuff
you have zero variants associated with
more itchy mosquito bites
that is weird you have zero variants
associated with generally
not feeling angry when hungry
zero variance with not feeling angry
when hungry that's weird
you have zero variance associated with
being less likely to have a fear of
heights
you have zero variance associated with
being more likely to have an apple body
shape than a pear body shape alright
this is starting to get edgy
so we're going to cut it but uh
interesting
interesting nonetheless uh
okay
so we've gotten that out of the way big
thank you
to yorn adolph yorn adolph has just
signed up on my website also thanks to
coliseum bertola who just signed up
on my website a new members 28 and 29
today also big thank you to spooky
rummage
and a few other people who grabbed
twitch subs
six in fact putting us at 35.
chakaseki wants to know if there's any
correlation between neanderthal dna and
beta male characteristics
i i assume so yeah
for sure amlo pulls through insisting
four kovacs during texas gas crisis
mexico was impacted
but managed way better despite
fear-mongering for strengthening
strengthening their national grid media
trying to smear mexico
i'm gonna have to uh look into that
i'm gonna have to look into that um
previous chat pepe xanadu wants me to
look at the previous chat
where is pepe's previous whoa
pepe um
previous chat yeah would you consider a
vegan flan that's the only previous chat
i see from you pepe oh no there it is
school to reopen soon in cali for a
nine-year-old four-year-old special
needs with heart condition
if he contracts covet he dies why is
biden rushing to reopen
biden doesn't seem to be rushing he
wants to have schools at least
partially open by a hundred days into
his presidency
that doesn't seem rushed what texas is
doing
certainly seems rushed my favorite drum
or symbol brands i you know i i for a
while
uh was a big sabian guy but i do like
the super dry
um zildjian uh particularly the
like the ultra dry zildjian ride
is a beautiful beautiful symbol
absolutely fantastic
fantastic symbol um
okay did i miss anything else here
abrasive says i'm proud of your massive
package david
maddie says when you read the congrats
letter it reminded me when dwight read
michael's recommendation from gm on the
office
my fellow office watchers are with me
yeah i wouldn't be able to say much
about that
thoughts reflections on your start to
now i mean you know it's
who knows i'd have to think about that
youtube youtube on the wall who's the
most golden of them all keep up the hard
work david pakman hashtag golden pacman
thank you thank you i very much
appreciate that
all right let's let's get back to seeing
what's going on in the senate here
to plan prepare for promote distribute
administer and monitor and track covet
19 vaccines
79 be use of funds the secretary acting
through the director of the centers for
disease control and prevention
and in consultation with other agencies
as applicable shall in conducting
activities referred to in subsection a
one conduct activities to enhance expand
and improve
nationwide covet really really powerful
stuff
uh going on there will i open the phone
lines yeah i
mean this is gonna take forever so i
would be open to opening the phone lines
um but i'm gonna have to hold hold
steady on our 100 members
now we do have oh people oh i wanted to
do this last time but i was not able to
pull it up
uh the all-time top sub gifters on
twitch these are some crooked numbers
a user who goes by the name i'm
inconsolable has
gifted 524 subs via twitch
and is the top sub gifter of all time
second most is david chadman
who has gifted 323 twitch subs
and then spudnik 19
is in third place with 258 gifted subs
also do you want to give some honorable
mentions to people who have been gifting
lately
including ky dizzle astro lycos
and boy meets minnie those are the
absolute
top gifters uh of all time
on our super chat
on our uh twitch chat and twitch stream
and then uh that's that's basically it
some of these other people i haven't
seen for a long time
oh odw d-i-n-c i don't know how that's
pronounced
they're in fourth place they've been
around recently
boy meets mini has gifted 72 but i don't
remember seeing boy meets many for a
while
um yeah david david chadman in second
place
daniel r says previous chat skipped oh
boy
daniel r
um let's see david let's turn on the
nightly news i've received the oh
darling let's turn on the nightly
news i've received the award for 100 000
followers a hopeful yet soon to be
disappointed david to his girlfriend
right absolutely
seinfeld is better than the office and
frasier combined obviously
no uh no question about it 21-inch
zildjian
sweet ride perfect ride crash hybrid
wow okay uh but in all seriousness
i am i am glad to open phone lines but
we would have to get some combination of
a hundred website members and twitch
subs in the meantime though
let me play some of what we call quote
good voicemails okay
good voicemails that people often ask
for
let's see what we've got here um
let's listen to this one oh david i got
a
conspiracy theory for you i do believe
that q
can be nothing nobody else but russia
the gru because they're the the uh
allegations are just so crazy it can't
be anybody else
they're the only ones that stand to gain
from this yet
okay so there's uh there's one voicemail
let's see what else we've got um
i'll give you guys a little insight into
like the multiple callers who call
multiple times in a row
i'll just pick a random one and th this
is somebody who called seven times in a
row let's see what they're up to
hi dave i've been called calling you a
bunch
he actually played me once
[Music]
you know i've been working through this
pandemic
as much as anyone right you know i mean
like
i saved some money i'm a low income
i'm on disability but i save some money
and i
end up losing my job at the end of may
and then i end up relapsing okay that's
sad
that's sad um
then they called back my point is
mr david pacquiao which would they read
they did from argentina
i could see i still total
i took i that's why i called you to fork
because i will defend your honor
all right so anyway that's someone they
called seven times so i'm not gonna play
all seven for you
um here's another this is a triple
caller
this person called three times in a row
the stand your ground law
that jeb bush passed you're gonna get a
confrontation down here in florida or
georgia or texas and it's gonna come
down to that
someone pulling a gun on someone else
just a thought all right all right then
they called back
clarence thomas's wife and i
participation
in busing people to this demonstration
which turned into a riot
these are the people who have to be
grabbed immediately i hope you comment
on that
tonight
all right and then they called back a
third time
that meeting at the trump hotel i wonder
if eric prince was there
or elliot abrams these are the kind of
guys these are the kind of things they
did in central america
these are the kind of things that
happened in hungary you had
sebastian gorka bragging all the time in
this match slap
i'd have him investigated every inch
that guy is dirty
that guy is dirty all right
um let's see who else we've got again
this is like every morning you know we
have about a hundred of these and i have
to go through them and find something
that's relevant for the
for the show um
all right here's this here's one on
cancel culture
hey dave so i'm watching your uh
show right now and you're talking about
cancel culture
and you're talking about how the
right republicans by the way notice that
my show is playing in the background
of every single one of these voicemails
these are all different people people
think that i exaggerate
it's so common that the no people don't
pause the show to call in
run out of ideas so
like i'm not people are noticing it in
the chat i'm not even mentioning it
because it's so common the last guy had
the same thing
ideas this cancel culture and
it's basically doesn't exist
but they're pretending to whatever
reason make it exist
you know i i'm not familiar this isn't
the same guy the other guy had a boston
accent i know it's similar but it's not
the same guy
you're i'm not sure how familiar you are
with
manipulation i'm sure you are but the
number one manipulation
is to make the other person think
that they're doing actually what you're
doing
but i'm struggling to follow that um
all right let's look at a couple of
others um
this one came in during the stream it's
about neanderthals let's listen
hey i just wanted to say something about
the word neanderthal
um everyone using it especially the
republicans who's pronouncing it wrong
you're not supposed to hit the th with a
light
it's supposed to be a hard t so
neanderthal yeah yeah yeah
instead neanderthal if neanderthal
right so that's a clarification i think
it's an important one
um let's see what this is so david i
have a question about
the basic fundamentals of yours and kyle
koenske's channel
um it seems that kyle
can't hit a million subs and you easily
blew
past that well let me check hold on
yeah it does say that that is true it
does say that just say a million that's
true
all right let's continue what is what is
he doing wrong with his channel
i have no idea i don't watch any shows
like mine to actually not gain
actual subs and viewership to his
channel because you're sitting at 1.3
million
subs you've gained 300k blown past 1
million and kyle gained
literally probably about 30 000. what is
the difference between your channel
and kyle's channel other than the sheer
quality
that i can see oh my god this is
aggressive i don't know guys i don't
know what other people are doing i'm not
gonna you know i have no interest in
criticizing kyle i have no idea what
he's doing on his channel
i don't even know how many subs he has
me it seems more that like kyle has just
kind of given up a little bit i mean he
did what
i mean i can't get all of it out on the
phone or now but like i just feel like
he's just become more and that's
a very negative message i don't love
that i don't like that voicemail
um let's see what else here's a glenn
greenwald
one hey david
um i just wanted to ask you
what in the
hell i almost centered myself but
whatever
what in the hell is going on
with glenn greenwald yeah
this guy just recently said that
um car he believes tucker carlson to be
a socialist
is that true did glenn say that i'm
trying not to talk about glenn greenwald
but because i
i think something's going on going on
emotionally with glenn
and he's lashed out at me a few times on
twitter
or twitter um i'm i'm kind of staying
away i just think something's going on
with him i don't know
it just doesn't feel like i'm
criticizing it
i don't know let's listen though you
mean to tell me
that a once progressive
with a huge platform a respected
platform
at least at one point um
is going to fall for the faux populism
the trojan horse right-wing populism of
a paleocon
of a listen a lot of people have fallen
for that
with uh with tucker
that's not unique
oh and the voicemail just glitched okay
so anyway that one's about tucker
carlson and glenn greenwald
um i'm just giving people a sense of
like what what comes in
um let's see
let's see here
let's take a listen to this hello dave
a long time listener i'm very impressed
with your show
but i think they ought to suggest more
when the capital was sacked
that the nuclear football was this is a
guy from king of the hill right
also also at risk
mike pence was in trouble the senate was
in trouble
but the nuclear football is at risk and
no one seems to
acknowledge that fact have a great day
all right so very polite message
although it's not totally clear what
it's about
um i think i had a voicemail from the
eggman
also who we love love love hearing from
where was that eggman voicemail hold on
a second
uh it was eggmania on the phone lines
eggman eggman eggman
where on earth did that eggman voicemail
go
oh here it is here's the egg man dave
i'm eating in my car i'm on my new diet
of bananas
oatmeal pineapple and baked potatoes
and the car in front of me is at a full
stop at a red light
and i think it's driver suppression
my new diet's awesome i love that guy's
new york accent that was the best part
of that call
shalom brother that's an inside joke
relating to a voicemail from earlier in
the week
now what that accent did you guys notice
how eggman says
bananas i say bananas he says bananas
is that a new york thing
nobody knows good
love it when people have no idea all
right uh here's a voicemail about andrew
cuomo this is a caller dave from
california who calls very frequently
david from california this thing with
governor
cuomo and sexual harassment
i worked for a big company in 1980
oh they constantly told me
hands off in other words
a friendly handshake
some company business
and even if they were your good friend
don't talk about personal affairs
inside the company grounds if you want
to go have a drink
do that outside the company
just don't do it in the company okay
all right there's dave from california
ellis says via super chat david i wish
you looked at twitch comments more i
look at them all the time
i look at them all the time more
importantly who's your favorite early to
mid 90s rapper i don't know who
who's early to mid 90s
people oh that's interesting every
people some people are saying every
single one of these voicemails
are better than troy york that's
interesting
that's interesting see okay so if tupac
was earl counts as early to mid 90s then
i would say tupac
let's see what else we've got here
someone on the
culture war yes hello david this is
yabbitz from marietta georgia
uh just wanted to read oh i think yabitz
is a super chatter
to your question on whether or not
some of these culture war things you
should still continue to go into
and i would like to persuade you that
yes i think so
you read some emails from an anti-vaxxer
that
sort of led to a dead end which is very
typical
that's exactly i like that description
of it it did lead to a complete and
total dead end
the sort of mentalities that are
launching and continuing these culture
wars
i mean you come right down to the
contradictions like the
cpac conference where they were asked to
wear masks because
this private property has got rules and
right conservatives normally are all for
business owners enforcing rules
beautiful point deciding who they want
to serve perfect
as you pointed out the same thing goes
with the hasbro company and mr potato
head
and the seuss foundation which decided
on its own to make a decision to said we
we're just not going to do these books
yep these contradictions are going to
make their way to a tiny percentage of
these people not your anti-vaxxer
emailer but one of the times somebody's
going to realize this is messed up
and i i think that anything that can be
done it doesn't require a lot amount of
time
but every single time we point out the
contradictions a tiny percentage are
going to be won over and those people
in turn will become more effective at
winning over all the others
in their circle that's interesting yeah
i think that that's actually an
interesting take
um and that's basically everything
that's that's all i've got um
yeah so those those are that's every
voicemail but we've cleared it all out
uh i think anyway sometimes people will
text the google voicemail line it's like
we're not looking at texts nobody's
looking at that so that's it that's
completely and totally cleared
all right very very good hope people
like that uh it's
it it really you know people wonder how
do how do the voicemails that get on
b end up being the ones that are chosen
it's because this is what i'm picking
from and i you know we love all the
callers but not everything lends itself
to to a 60 minute
60 minute show thank you to igor morice
who just signed up at joinpackman.com
igor i love it and i appreciate it
cockeyed rooster says david i think the
republicans have been completely
consumed by the libertarian fascist
wings of the party now you see the
prevalence of conspiracy thinking
that i've always dominated these two
groups no doubt
um one of the things i've been pointing
out for a while is a lot of libertarians
are just conspiracy theorists they're
not really libertarians
some are of course but oftentimes
libertarian is how
a right-wing nut that doesn't really
want to be part of the republican party
will
distance themselves it's like no no what
what separates you from republicans
isn't that you're a libertarian
economically
it's that you're absolutely off the wall
conspiracy theorist
what myers-briggs personality type are
you i don't know uh
let me see hold on could it be entj
is that possible is that a thing the
commander
entj
um it's been so long since i took that
stuff
commanders you may know steve jobs
gordon ramsay margaret thatcher
fdr jim carrey uh oh he's kooky
whoopi goldberg that's cool harrison
ford
um
francis underwood from house of cards
holy [ __ ]
i thought i was entj that's what i
that's what i remember
i don't remember what each of them stand
for okay let me do one other thing i've
i've had requests from people
to to go over one of the old wacky
interviews that i did
and kind of see what my thoughts are on
it now i don't know which one it should
be
once we did this with the richard
spencer interview
i could do it with an old um westboro
baptist church interview maybe that's an
interesting idea steve cancel says i
missed the super chat
okay sorry steve why did ron johnson
make him read the whole bill just a
silly delay tactic
yeah yeah yeah it's just it's just a
delay tactic
that's it um that's all it is
maybe i'll do let's see david pakman
westborough let's just find an old
westboro baptist church interview
and see what's up with it
um which one should i do
maybe the one where the lady called me a
tit mouse
let's check that one out this is
something i haven't looked at in a long
time let's review
quick interview we're really going back
to a true classic
this was when one of the daughters of
here we go
joining me is margie phelps from the
westboro baptist church immediately
after the shooting at sandy hook school
the westboro baptist church announced
that it would be picketing
the vigil as well as i believe some look
at how much better our audio quality is
now
of the funerals margie let's cut right
to the chase
what's the reason do you still plan to
pick at funerals and what's the reason
for that
every time god reaches down into this
nation
and smacks you hard and gets your
attention
we're going to come forth before that's
our job that's our mission
so one of the ways he's doing that
increasingly
by these shooters they're getting
younger and their numbers are getting
bigger
we've told you for over 20 years that if
you
keep up this path proud sin you're going
to bring mayhem
to the land and now you've waxed words
and now
the reaction shot chase for same-sex
marriage
connecticut was one of the first states
to come out of same-sex marriage
you guys think you can brute force away
the standard of god
it's not gonna happen you heard it here
first okay but margie what's the plan
with
what's the plan with the funeral
specifically right she's filibustering
me
soon connecticut is going to look like a
teeth
party many more shooters many more
dead are coming and the plan with
connecticut are you kidding
me there's already been thousands of our
words put out in the airwaves
we'll continue on the course we're on
how did i have the patience for these
people back then
okay but are you are you going to pick
at the funerals of the kids
wherever we can put these signs up
including those funerals
is what we'll do okay and specifically i
mean i understand that you believe
broadly that anything bad that happens
in this country
is god's punishment for what you
consider to be the acceptance of
homosexuality but i mean these
kids and we have a lot of their pictures
here i mean what what did
little jack pinto do to deserve
jonathan it's a good question phelps
there with a god sent the shooter
sign right or i mean any any of these
right you know olivia engel
what did she do what's the point of
being there
truth is and name them all those
children are better off dead than in
this nation
without every child of that age in this
nation
outside of westboro baptist church is
without hope
they are on their mother's milk taught
to be proud sinners and rebels
these people are out of their minds yeah
against the god of glory
there's no hope for those children no
that's nonsense
worse they died look at your hands
david pacman their blood is on your
hands
and all the rest the media and all the
rest of the preachers
and all the rest leaders their blood is
on your hands
if you ever cracked a bible you would be
familiar with the fact
that when you enrage the king of glory
the lord god jehovah
there's nothing more pro-life than this
yeah on the scene with destruction
and he's no respecter of age he kills
infants in his wrath furthermore no one
is born
innocent so get off all that nonsense
it's modeling
it's unscriptural it's unhelpful
at the time if you don't want more of
those dead children
stop what you're doing margie um there's
been a
if you gave a wrath backside you or
anyone else in this nation if you really
cared barack obama
we're going to have to agree to disagree
on this born for your sins
you would change course before you have
thousands of dead
laying at your feet i wanna
i know the bible stuff but let's just
try to keep it concise a little because
there are more things
incredibly there's actually we actually
have a lot of things to talk about
that's actually kind of funny it's hard
to believe i'd have a
big agenda with this woman but i
actually do that's pretty damn funny
this is like watching some i don't even
i have no memory of this like i remember
doing it
i'm actually cracking myself up here
talk to a lot of people
uh there have been about 200 articles
but just to be
clear the only thing you and i are
talking about today
is connecticut and same-sex marriage
don't waste my time
you don't have a big enough audience for
me to waste my time
so don't go off any rabbit trails no no
i i'm gonna stick to
i thank you for keeping me focused
margie because i want to stick to
another issue which is
several hundred articles are now out
about anonymous
excuse me margie let me see if we can
get a question in here if i may
start talking about anonymous the
irrelevant
criminal cowards whose names god knows
and who will let the criminal
authorities deal with
then then that's when i use my skype
hangout telephone so stick to the
issue of today the issue of today is
connecticut
dead children for same-sex marriage and
we'll continue to chat
but have you been attacked by anonymous
and they're lurking in the background
all the time anonymous
is irrelevant they're they're so
yesterday okay now meanwhile
meanwhile the real issue is if you could
shut us
up if you could shut us up
the lord god will find someone else to
say these words in fact
christ said he'll find some stones
so look for the stones to start talking
margie i wanna
okay give me an opportunity margie to
talk to you
uh one-on-one here let's look i i i
against my better judgment maybe
um i wanna maybe try to work out some
david you need us way worse than we need
you so stop all that nonsense
anonymous is irrelevant and often let's
forget about anonymous for a second sure
margie i'm sorry shirley's her sister
hey carlos shirley let me just can i
make a proposal
for you she does look like james spader
in the blacklist
that's hilarious that's a that's maybe
the best
a twitch message i've ever seen she she
looks like james spader in the blacklist
that's insane oh man all right let's
keep going
listen to a proposal from me is that and
then you can reject it or accept it it's
your choice
it's not what it is okay my goal
is to keep you and your signs away from
the funerals of these kids in
connecticut and as you said
your goal is for as many people as
possible
to hear your message which you have made
a number of times on this show so
and i may regret this and i think my
audience may not like this but what i
want to propose to you is
would you be willing to say you will
stay away from the funerals of the
children
in exchange i would provide you a 30
minute
uninterrupted it won't be me
interrupting you and saying oh but what
about this and that we will give you 30
minutes really to put together it can be
a video that you put together or
whatever you want it's an idea we'll put
it on our youtube channel which has 25
million views we're on 160 tv and radio
stations across
25 we're almost at a billion views now
wow
that was a while ago the country we get
50 million views a month now
we're on direct tv and dish network and
32 million homes
i know that my audience will not like
this but i feel like i may be doing
something good i would be willing to
compromise
and offer you that opportunity if you
agree simply
stay away from the funerals of these few
kids and
and you'll reach way more people this
way which i don't like i really don't
but i just want to see if we can maybe
broker some kind of agreement
i'll float the proposal okay so we were
hoping to hear back about whether or not
our proposal was accepted
there were a number of phone calls and
trying to yeah needless to say it wasn't
that's interesting
that that's this is pretty compelling
stuff i i don't i have it's like
it's all brand new to me let's check out
one other one
pacman peter le barbera this is another
guy
um let me see here
hold on which one was this
oh no no no no not pete no no it's uh
david pakman
uh michael brown
yeah this is it check this out check out
this guy
um yeah this is this guy's nuts
this is a mess i am at least to america
wait no
no no no this isn't it there's one where
we actually see him
i guess it's this one this guy is what
they call a messianic jew
he's a jew for jesus it's it's crazy
and uh let's let's listen to a little
bit of this one
is now in support of gay marriage well
it's no surprise
actually for two reasons first in 1996
he came out clearly
and unequivocally in writing when he was
running for office saying that he
supported legalizing same-sex marriage
and he would oppose any efforts against
that so the statements he made in 2004
2008 when he said as a christian he
opposed same-sex marriage and marriage
was a sacred thing and
and gay marriage was not a civil right i
took all those statements with a grain
of salt
especially because in 2008 uh the same
year
he made his very positive statement and
the debate with rick warren
he wrote a letter to the democratic club
in
in san francisco a gay and lesbian
democratic group in san francisco
and explained to them that he opposed
proposition 8 the marriage amendment
there
i'm going to skip ahead this guy
eventually like cuts me off because he
doesn't like my questions it's
from what i recall it's pretty female it
would be as foreign to talk about two
men or two women waiting in the bible
as it would be to talk about marrying an
alien or marrying a goat it's completely
foreign
practically died of aids and boswell's
stuff has been completely refuted by
church scholars just study it out
the reason that he discovered this stuff
is because he completely misread the
text
so so let's let's focus on today for a
second let's focus on today
where is marriage defined as a man and a
woman
it has always been throughout american
history from the foundation of our
nation it was always understood the only
reason
it was understood it was defined
somewhere you understood so tell me
where is it
it has been fine in every legal document
having to do with marriage
david i i actually thought i i guess i
didn't know what show i was getting on
no insult but i thought this was a
serious issue a serious discussion about
this issue
and it's not where someone's going to
deny every okay every you research
every single marriage document in
american
history that has been recognized by the
government until the last few years
where some states change things there
was one definition and one definition
only it was the union of a man and a
woman it's the only definition
you'll find in every single dictionary
that's ever been written and every
single legal document recognized by the
government so tell us
where where can one look up that
definition
just every time you work with everybody
legally
okay tell you what start with every
dictionary that has been written in
america
a legal document the dictionary do you
know what if you looked up
the n-word hold on a second if you
looked up the n-word for a black person
100 years ago in a dictionary
what is a dictionary david okay
tell you what i am going to have to get
going soon because i actually thought
this was a
serious interview not not a joke thing
not something that's just
trying to set people up for quotes so
here's the deal you go
to any court house in america
okay and just ask them for any marriage
document they have
from 10 years ago 20 years ago 50 years
ago 100 years ago okay
very very simple i don't have to tell
you where to find marriage documents you
perfectly know how to do that
and if you were why is the frame rate
two frames per second by the way
just didn't actually information i'd be
sharing it with you
i'm i really am interested in
information i'm i'm
bothered that you don't think i
genuinely
don't know that the only legal
definition of marriage that we have ever
had since the founding of america has
been the union of a man and a woman
the thing is it's not whether i know or
don't know i just ask questions and i'm
asking you so so tell me
what is the document that defines that
because you're saying well go to a court
and ask them for documents that refer to
marriage but
long enough ago where it wasn't already
legal like it is for example in
massachusetts
what what use is that dr brown let's do
this
i'll send you a copy of my book a queer
thing happened to america a queer thing
happened to america
and get the larger overview of gay
activism and its effects on history and
its agenda and its goals
after you've gone through that with 1500
plus endnotes and massive research in
there
there's a really there's a typical thing
that these these guys or gals do
which is they they tell you about a book
that they want you to read but they
mention the number of endnotes like you
should i should in order to
qualify for a conversation i've got to
review the 1500 endnotes
and we can follow up with other
questions you have dr brown you don't
set the guidelines for what's required
reading to conduct an interview i didn't
think the things you should read before
talking
what kind of a thing is that to say let
me let me review your 1500 endnotes this
is bizarre isn't it
no no it's not i'm telling you if you're
looking for information i'm happy to
give it to you but tell you what i wish
you a great day i hope you do well
and blessings on your work all right
well i have many more questions for you
it just doesn't sound like you're you're
uh
ready or able to answer those we're
focusing on documenting no no i
i am perfectly able i do hundreds of
interviews but not not mockery
interviews so david
you have a good day but i just want to
encourage you to be a serious host next
time around and
ask questions that are so readily
available to everyone and that no one
even
argues with it's one thing to dispute
david tell you what i've got better
things to do right now
if you want to continue to attack and
say this is not a serious interview it's
a mockery
feel free to make the ad hominems feel
free to hang up sir you're free to do
that
all right god bless you man i wish you
well
oh that was a classic man that i there's
some stuff in the archives that really
is
is worthy of review that is some uh
interesting stuff
i don't know that i'd man that's
uh i can only the only valid
uh reference material are his 1500
endnotes anything from outside of that
would not be considered
but not would not be considered valid
that is something else
all right let's check back in on on the
senate here 2021 but on or before august
29
2021 the recovery benefit payable under
the subparagraph shall be in the amount
of eight hundred dollars b
clarification on authority to use funds
funds appropriated under sub-paragraph b
of section 285 of the railroad
unemployment insurance act
right so now they're going to do that
let me just look at a couple other super
chats q
todd says jesus was a lover of men it
said so in 1 corinthians 11
3. i couldn't tell you one way or the
other i live just outside topeka where
the westboro baptist churches sucks
being around these clowns they have day
jobs in the city
i can't believe i share the same town
with this woman
remember when anonymous live hacked
their website yeah
i'd rather be back in iraq than live in
her head
what's the deal with the voicemail
number it doesn't work i type the full
219
to david p and it doesn't work i don't
know everybody's leaving voicemails even
as we were
even as we were playing them people were
uh people were leaving voicemails
check my previous super chat says sam
smith
i would appreciate an updated reading
list from you whatever you're currently
or planning to read would even consider
becoming a member for that knowledge
okay yeah i can look at that right now
uh i'm reading as i mentioned
travels with charlie by john steinbeck
and
um a billion dollar loser
about the fall of wework fiction i just
finished up
one of um blake crouch's early works
erie
and now i started oh hold on it's um
james baldwin uh something mountain
what's the name of the
book go tell it on the mountain by
by the great james baldwin and then i
also recently picked up
infinite jest by david foster wallace
thousand pages it's a big boy but i've
been i've never read any david foster
wallace find him to be a fascinating guy
and um i plan to
read that next i also grabbed kim
stanley robinson's green
mars that's the second of three books in
the mars
trilogy oh okay and people are saying i
missed some twitch subs
uh d storm 99 thank you so much for the
twitch sub i
uh very very much appreciate that all
right guys i have to head out i actually
i i
shockingly i actually have something to
do today i've got to go do so this is
going to be the end of the stream these
guys are going to be going late into the
night
employment benefits provided under such
section 2c
2d yeah so you guys can pick it up on
pbs if it interests you
and then once it's actually time to vote
and it looks like something will happen
legislatively
i will be right back all right thanks
everybody let's raid
somebody on twitch let's see who's
streaming
uh man no no uh nobody streaming that i
think would acknowledge us
let's oh this is this will be fun let's
uh raid
this is a chess streamer but this is
what we've got let's raid
daniel nareditsky all right guys come
over with me if you're watching on
twitch we're going to raid
a daniel naraditsky and we will monitor
for the vote and then eventually
whenever what happens we will be back
thanks everybody
you